en este vídeo haremos un viaje a las
células eucariotas y me gustaría empezar
recordando que queremos decir cuando
hablamos de una célula eucariota hablar
de una célula eucariota significa que
dentro de la célula existen organelos
también llamados orgánulos unidos a
membranas pero eso qué significa
bueno podemos verlos como sub
compartimentos que se encuentran dentro
de la célula en este vídeo veremos
algunos de esos organelos más
importantes unidos a membranas que hacen
que las células sean eucariotas
empecemos con uno de los componentes que
se encuentra en todas las células la
membrana celular aquí tenemos la
membrana celular la dibujo grande para
que tengamos mucho espacio esta es
nuestra membrana celular pero acuérdense
que aunque nosotros analicemos el corte
transversal de las células podemos
imaginar las tridimensionales las
células son prácticamente esféricas
pero no completamente porque pueden
tener diferentes formas ahora todas las
células bueno aunque a veces hay algunas
excepciones como las que hemos visto en
otros vídeos podemos decir que la
mayoría de las células contienen
información genética en la forma de adn
este es el adn y una de las
características claves de una célula
eucariota es que la información genética
se encuentra en el interior de un
organelos unido a una membrana y esa
membrana que rodea al adn se conoce como
la membrana nuclear
esta es la membrana nuclear y le pondré
un poco de sombra para que podamos
apreciarla en tres dimensiones alrededor
del adn entonces este es nuestro primer
organelos unido a una membrana el núcleo
ahora el núcleo está conectado a otro
organelos unido a una membrana y esto lo
estudiaremos más a fondo en otros vídeos
aquí estoy dibujando a algunos poros o
agujeros en la membrana nuclear y estos
poros están conectados a algo más
llamado retículo endoplasmático el
retículo endoplasmático consiste en
varias capas de membranas trataré de
dibujar si quisiéramos extender todo
este retículo que hay desde los poros
hasta las membranas en capas
obtendríamos una gran área de superficie
aquí no voy a dibujar todo esto
alrededor del núcleo pero en muchas
células el retículo endoplasmático si se
encuentra alrededor de todo el núcleo
este es solo un diagrama aproximado y
aquí tenemos el retículo endoplasmático
endoplasmático que como mencioné en
vídeos anteriores sería un gran nombre
para una banda y lo que ocurre en el
retículo endoplasmático es que cuando
nos encontramos en el proceso de tomar
la información genética del adn que como
mencionamos en otros vídeos es
transcrito en micro rn ahora el micro
arn contiene esa información y el micro
arn sale del núcleo por algunos de los
poros y busca su camino hasta un
ribosoma que se encuentra unido a la
membrana del retículo endoplasmático por
ejemplo supongamos que aquí tenemos un
ribosoma y aquí tenemos algunos otros
ribosomas como dijimos en vídeos
anteriores los ribosomas toman la
información genética del micro
rn y después lo traducen en proteínas
podemos decir que los ribosomas son los
sintetizadores de proteínas aquí tenemos
un ribosoma algunos ribosomas pueden
estar unidos al retículo endoplasmático
pueden estar flotando por el citoplasma
por ejemplo aquí tenemos un ribosoma
libre
libre ahora a la parte del retículo
endoplasmático en la que se encuentran
unidos los ribosomas se le conoce como
retículo endoplasmático rugoso los
ribosomas hacen que se vea rugoso cuando
lo analizamos en el microscopio solo no
escribiré como r y rugoso para no
escribir todo el nombre completo pero
también hay algunas partes del retículo
endoplasmático en las que no hay
ribosomas y como esas partes se ven
lisas en el microscopio se les conoce
como parte del ridículo endoplasmático
liso en la célula también existen
algunas otras cosas como el cuerpo de
gaulle y nuevamente un nombre muy
fascinante como muchos de los nombres en
biología el cuerpo de golgi se parece
mucho a el retículo endoplasmático pero
no está unido a la membrana nuclear
imaginen que este es el cuerpo de goji
que es muy bueno para empacar moléculas
e incluso proteínas que se acaban de
producir y las empaca para que puedan
ser utilizadas
fuera de la célula pero veremos eso con
más detalle en otros vídeos en los que
una proteína pasa por el cuerpo de golgi
donde es envuelta y después es llevada
al exterior de la célula bien otro
organelos unido a una membrana y que
probablemente es el más famoso fuera del
núcleo es la central eléctrica de la
célula a la que se le llama mitocondria
la dibujaré por aquí la mitocondria me
gusta mucho porque es muy interesante de
hecho la mitocondria tiene su propio adn
y todo el adn de las mitocondrias
proviene de nuestra madre por eso es muy
importante para trazar el linaje materno
y aquí es en donde se produce el atp
esta es la mitocondria que como les
mencioné es la central eléctrica o
fuente de poder de la célula algo muy
interesante sobre la mitocondria es que
los biólogos evolutivos creen que como
las mitocondrias tienen su propio adn
probablemente antes eran células
independientes pero en algún punto del
pasado comenzaron a
en simbiosis dentro de lo que serían las
células de nuestros ancestros y con el
tiempo se volvieron tan codependientes
que empezaron a replicarse juntas y
probablemente así fue como la
mitocondria se volvió parte de las
células eucariotas ahora sí esta célula
eucariota fuera una célula vegetal
también tendríamos algo llamado
cloroplasto nosotros no lo tenemos
porque no realizamos la fotosíntesis
aquí tenemos un cloroplasto y al
analizar su interior podemos encontrar
las pilas de ti la coidh es
entonces este es el cloroplasto y este
solo lo encontramos en células de
plantas y algas las células animales no
tienen cloroplasto aquí es en donde se
lleva a cabo la fotosíntesis por otro
lado también existen algunos organelos
que son menos famosos que la mitocondria
el cloroplasto o el núcleo y uno de
ellos es la vacuola en las plantas las
vacuolas generalmente son muy grandes y
aquí como la célula es tridimensional
voy a dibujarla sobre todo esto en una
planta la vacuola ocupa un espacio
significativo y de hecho puede darle la
estructura a la planta debido a su gran
tamaño la vacuola contiene agua y
enzimas e incluso es vista como un
compartimento de almacenamiento pero
también puede contener enzimas que
ayudan a digerir cosas es decir que
ayudan a descomponer cosas para que
puedan ser utilizadas de alguna forma y
entonces esta es una vacuola
y claro no solamente existen células
vegetales sino que también la podemos
encontrar en células animales pero en
las células vegetales son bastante
visibles otra cosa que de alguna manera
está relacionada con algunas de las
funciones que realiza la vacuola y que
en su mayoría se asocia con las células
animales pero que ahora también existe
evidencia de que se encuentra en las
células vegetales es el lisosoma aquí
tenemos el lisosoma y este también es un
compartimento que contiene muchas
enzimas en su interior y que son útiles
para alisar o dicho de otra manera
descomponer los productos de desecho
mientras la célula vive e incluso
sustancias extrañas que no son muy
útiles para las células entonces el
lisosoma contiene muchas enzimas que
ayudan a descomponer cosas vamos a
dejarlo aquí estas no son todas las
estructuras de las células eucariotas
pero son las estructuras más importantes
con las que podemos apreciar que existen
muchos órganos
los también llamados orgánulos unidos a
membranas en las células eucariotas y
para que quede claro aún cuando yo les
mostrará todas las estructuras aún así
no podríamos representar toda la
complejidad que hay en una célula aquí
lo más importante es darnos cuenta de
que las células son increíblemente
complejas y contienen todo tipo de
estructuras en ellas que ayudan a
transportar y mover cosas por todo su
interior si pudiéramos encogernos y ver
dentro de una célula se vería mucho más
compleja que la ciudad más compleja que
existe aquí ocurren todo tipo de
actividades las cosas se mueven de un
lado a otro la célula se replica y copia
cosas este es sólo el principio apenas
hemos dicho algunas cosas de la
complejidad de la unidad más básica de
la vida pero bueno terminemos este vídeo
hasta luego